I never really talked to her fully about
it from her perspective of like why not
I just know from my dad so
um I like just growing up in general for
me after like all these incidents or
whatever I like I didn't want him to put
my self on anyone else so like I kind of
like held myself in a lot when it came
to communicating or talking about
certain things because I knew my mom
from this point she had so much on her
shoulder so now she has to like really
be hey well your dad had a dresser on
his back all right let's go mom you know
what I'm saying dad's got a dresser of
bullets on his back
the Honeydew with y'all
subscribe today
[Music]